du erinnerst dich an olaf scholz seinen
berühmten pullover er auf dem flur
hätten klar als ganz genau nach
washington zu joe biden zum
us-präsidenten seinem antrittbesuch dort
das war der pullover cool haben die
einen gesagt lässt sich der kanzler darf
der das
die andere jetzt kommen dollar erhöht
jetzt kommt im manual makro gestern
fotografiert und man muss sagen dieses
foto mit ein bisschen erbat und rudi ja
das wurde im lese gemacht aber warum
also erträgt auf die mit der aufschrift
ca 10 dabei handelt es sich um die
kennzeichnung der spezialeinheit der
luftwaffe und raumfahrt von frankreich
und viele haben sofort gesagt jetzt das
ist sozusagen selensky leid was man da
macht der will sich irgendwie annähernd
in diesen zeiten in diesen kriegszeiten
das ist der selensky hody also dieser
fotovergleich immer wieder zu sehen
aktuell im netz das sorgt für
gesprächsstoff heute der hoodie von
emanuel makro